hey I also go and raise my today we're
gonna do three free games and pewds the
time where I find three games and we
play them you must literally be dying to
see what's about to happen next with
that intro well played our Prague this
is a game that you bros suggested I can
tell that someone put a lot of effort
into paint in this probably in the age
of five or six I don't know what what to
say I'm just very immersed oh that is
indeed the appropriate sound of a frog
so if I logged in I can see how much
time I've spent derping there's also a
versus mode that doesn't work just for
gender equality there is a pink one
because everyone knows the pink frogs
are the female one that's it that's
[ __ ] it you run suggest this [ __ ] to
me thank you I really enjoyed it ten out
of ten all right [ __ ] it I'll play a
game that costs money I don't think it
would be that bad so this is card
drifter simulator so this is card
drifter simulator and everything I touch
explodes I don't know why for some
reason I thought it was a good idea to
pack my car filled with vegetables I'm
an explosive I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened there
funky music wow I like it I reminds me
of in the 90s I'm just kidding
I don't remember anything from the 90s
whoa you guys got played son you got got
played he teleport so I would die what a
genius so my goal is to survive this
house for as long as possible I'd see
how long we can do no exit don't tell me
what to do I'll fine game one field to
zero I'm gonna get his left there we go
I got his mailbox hey you will have to
go and buy an holy [ __ ] what are the
houses made of do they forget to
superglue their houses together in
America feel bad for whoever owns that
house there oh look I'm twerking hey
cops look at my boot with a girl mmm
oh my god they're all crashing I'm a
genius don't crash now oh my god there's
kids everywhere I'm like a Nicki Minaj
here my anaconda don't know get damn it
my anger Connor don't much Amick [ __ ]
reeseman what if I just do this what why
are the cops so set into driving into me
oh look a donut shop and a cop
coincidence I think not [ __ ] that was
actually fun I like that game it's not
free though but hey I did dart frog so
next game is also a game that's been
suggested by you most if it's even half
as good as dart frog then I might just
have to kill it okay so this one is cold
um I don't know actually
I don't speak Korean but I would say
major [ __ ] what's that I can't say
that they're gonna nuke my apartment um
all right the text says a majorly
handsome man boy let's do this we're
playing as kim joon kim jung kim joon
kim jong kim jeong-hoon said his name
kim jong hoon I don't know but I do know
that he has wonderfully fantastic pants
and they are fitting him quite nicely
can I say that all right cool let's go
for Drive we don't have a golf ball
either but I guess you don't need that
oh that it is what a nice shot
hole-in-one holy [ __ ] there we go again
let's try this out see what we get it's
a hole-in-one again what are the chances
let's see if we can do this oh my god
it's another holy wine it doesn't matter
what I do it's all holding once God come
on man what yeah now you're being
ridiculous in the far distant land as a
whole and we hit it oh my god I don't
even have to play I can play this with
my face look Wow okay I guess I'm not
that good
oh my face is that good Josh what about
you Edgar
hey hey wake up wake up you know son he
doesn't want to wake up Edgar come on
you have to play the game
I see if you're good enough Edgar all
right okay here you go Wow
you're the most untalented pug in the
world are you sleeping no wait no wait
no way I take it back hole in one
holy why that cat oh come on kiss me
come on you have to kiss Wow
embarrassed by my dog he's really sleepy
are you on drugs
well it has great gameplay great death
great ass crack I would say and I would
probably rate this million out of a
million are we good they're not gonna
nuke us all right I better move on to
the next game before something bad
happens
all right the final game is crawl worm
crawl it's a free game it's a game by Q
skin flicks great chaps let's play it
press f to extend J to extend f jg h god
this is really hard
what the [ __ ] is this oh I got it I got
a great pattern here oh god this is
pissing me off oh I got it I got the
pattern keep crawling your brave worm
escape your impenetrable boot Doom no
way that's not it in in pain
whatever Oh God don't make her lose the
pattern oh my god what is that atrocious
girl we're the love of God and all
that's holy
keep crawling this is like [ __ ] except
nothing is our guide Oh God do you want
he wants to die this is the words
world's first suicidal worm Oh God don't
lose the pattern don't think about it
don't think about it Oh God Oh God I
know it's getting close
ah no not today yeah yet boo boo boo
really this game is scarier than amnesia
let's try that again okay it says how
long I have to go like as soon as you
lose the pattern it's over
uh-huh okay what what my butt oh god the
concentration level it's higher than the
concentrate out of my nips the doctor
said it's fine
don't worry about it Bryce I'm fine come
on 102 centimeters left oh gods shut up
shut your mouth how does the fish move
anyway I get the were moving I don't get
the fresh river come on getting that
stop shut up text shut up nope yes wow
you made it oh man I look good I look
like someone landed face front on their
erection that's what I look like
great game great graphics great gameplay
great life great story great soundtrack
great everything I feel like my life has
been lifted how about G Buress well
aren't you depressing I'm just kidding
here you go this has been great that was
three three games with boots hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did go ahead and
leave a like I'll leave all the links in
the description and you can enjoy them
all yourself because they're all free
except that one game and hey what are
you gonna do as always stay awesome
Rosen thank you for watching
[Music]